- All right, so this
Vandaveon and Mike again.
You know, hey, what's up,
"Key & Peele"?
We ain't heard back yet.
You know, the show
is still good, man.
Y'all still doing your thing.
But I ain't gonna lie
to you, man.
You still making mistakes, dawg.
- Could be a little bit
better, though.
Yeah, straight up.
- Still making mistakes,
for real, man.
Like, in this week's show, man,
y'all had that scene
called "Flicker," and whatnot.
You know the scene, man.
Like, you know,
in the first part,
he in the kitchen
and get flicked.
Then, the second part,
in the toilet, he get flicked.
Then, he out at the grave site,
and the grave come up and flick
him in the nose, right?
And that was all good, man.
Y'all made one mistake, dawg.
Y'all should have
made them fingers dicks.
- Dicks, man.
Slap on the face
with dicks.
- I mean, that's my shit
right there, man.
- Slap on the nose
with dick.
Slap on the face
- I mean, that's my shit, man.
Why wouldn't you turn
them fingers into dicks?
Should have been like,
"I need you in the kitchen,"
flick him with a dick.
- [laughing]
- You know
what I'm talking about?
Then you take his ass
over to--in the toilet,
and then that makes
a lot of sense.
That makes perfect sense.
Just flick him with a dick.
- With a dick.
- And then at the end, man,
when he go to that grave,
he talking about, "Hey, man,
you didn't get me,
you didn't get me,"
bone dick.
He's having a bone dick!
[laughter]
- Bone dick coming
out the ground, nigga.
Bone dick coming
out the ground.
- And then when you add
close-up,
this nigga's talking about,
"What's down there?"
Blip, hit this motherfucker
in the nose with a dick.
- And then, eating
chicken wings later,
and they lickin' dick.
- Yeah.
[laughing]
- Dick,
you got to lick dick.
- You should have put that
in there, man.
Tell 'em, say it again, Mike.
Say it, they might not
have heard it--say it again.
- Nah, nigga, you say it.
- No, say it, dude, go ahead.
- You said it.
- Okay, man.
He talking about, like,
if you was eating chicken wings,
and then you had, like,
sauce on your dick fingers,
and...
[laughing]
- Shit's nasty, though.
That's just stupid.
That's just stupid, son.
Quit being stupid.
Quit being stupid, though.
- He puts them little dicks
in his mouth!
- I've said way more funny
things than that, nigga.
- [laughing]
Seriously, "Key & Peele,"
come on, man.
Why you ain't hire us, man?
- What y'all doing?
- Our shit is clearly funny,
niggas.
- Shit is late.
- Seriously, man,
we know when the show end.
If y'all don't start
taking our shit serious...
- Yeah.